but I mean I think I'm right they're
saying that I'm Stein some some people
have said to me Einstein didn't believe
from quantum mechanics that seems to be
silly I think what he said was quantum
mechanics is obviously true I just don't
think your theories are right so would
he be on your side yeah
would he be closer to right he just felt
that the theory as Heisenberg and Bohr
came up with it was just obviously not
right well it was relatively right but
he felt that it didn't have the overall
correct theoretical shape and he was
interested in something like a hidden
variable kind of completion but not of
an ordinary kind okay you can't say
hidden variable without telling people
so this is one of the various
interpretive is it fair to say that
hidden variables is making a comeback
because it is a matter of fashion I mean
in in fashion for us as flared trousers
and kipper ties for this lot it's
many-worlds or hidden variables or is it
is hidden variables coming back and can
you tell them what it is I think it's so
you use the word hidden variables right
at the beginning when I was explaining
what it was so I'm just following your
lead oh don't blame me I'm about just
right so the idea of a so-called hidden
variable is that if you take the normal
mathematical descriptions in quantum
mechanics it doesn't seem to tell you
all of the things you think there might
be said about how the world is and the
idea is there might be some actual
variables in the world which we're not
seeing hence hidden which do fill fill
in all the details so there's no
vagueness perhaps because in fact
there's there is a more specific
description that's going on underneath
it's just one that we're ignorant of so
I think it's fair to say that in some
ways dad's preferred option for a
surpassing or completing quantum theory
would be a species of hidden variable
theory but one which is relaxed about
backwards influence in time but in terms
of them making a comeback
we're think with all of these
interpretations collapse hidden
variables were actually there are
probably increasing numbers of adherents
of all of them because we're actually
understanding what's involved of them in
them better and in some ways it's quite
good to have a plurality of views you've
got serious people seriously developing
them in both the hidden variables
program and collapse programs you've got
genuine physics to do as well as just
philosophy so you actually have to show
how these things could become
in various ways to work in high-energy
physics and so on in particle physics
and whether or not ultimately they're
successful is probably down to whether
or not you can get those kinds of models
to work to build so it's basically kind
of a physics question not a philosophy
question but I think there's more of
everything and that's surely a good
thing
you